It's time to talk about
the Power Query formula language or as it's more commonly and lovingly known,
M. M is a mashup query language,
simply meaning that it's a language designed to help you filter and combine your data.
If you're curious, M is a functional programming language.
If you have experience working with functional languages, great.
If not, don't worry about it.
You won't need to develop a deep understanding of M code for this course.
We'll just look at the basics in order to give you a solid foundation.
You may wonder, why not just do everything with the Power Query user interface?
Well, the interesting thing is that as we update,
we make the Power Query editor create and generate M code for
us based on the buttons you push or the columns you add in the Power Query interface.
That's right, this whole time,
Power Query has been working hard creating M code in the background.
How do you see it? There are a few different ways.
M code is made visible on the advanced query editor that you see on the left,
which includes every individual step that you take.
But there's that more user-friendly query settings
pane on the right that we've played with a little bit so far,
which has that user-friendly interpretation of those steps.
However, these are two sides of the same coin.
You'll be able to see how each step is
reflected in both and when you make changes to one,
it'll be reflected in the other.
The M code in Advanced Editor can seem
really daunting the first time that you make use of it,
but it's much easier to wrap your head around
once you understand what the basic logic is.
Essentially M code is going to define the source of
the data that you've determined during the initial get data setup,
it will navigate to the specific source details such as an Excel spreadsheet tab.
Then it will name and notate each change using
the M code formula language while referencing the last step each time,
at which point you will continue to repeatedly add new steps for
each desired change until you are done with all desired query transformations.
As you will see, each step explicitly references the last,
which always makes me think of knitting where you
connect the prior rope stitches to the last.
Without this connection to the last row,
you end up with a hole in your knitting or an error in your M code.
Let's take a look at this first with some pseudocode.
The M code and the Advanced Editor will start with let source and define the source link.
Next, it will provide more specific coordinates for
Power Query to use to navigate to the right information in that source.
The easiest example of this is with Excel,
where there'll be the name of a tab or a table.
With the first applied step,
your M code will automatically provide a name,
which is what I have here in green,
and then it will reference the blue source info step above.
Then with the next step,
it will apply a new unique name,
which I have here in purple,
and it will again reference the prior step,
that is in green.
The same logic continues,
applied step three in pink with a reference to the prior step in purple,
and then an aquamarine step,
which references an applied step in pink until you close with in,
and then the name of the last step.
A little bit like weaving in the ends of
your code like you would if you were knitting a sweater.
Using the produce M code from our produce query,
you can see that the M code is similar to what we saw in
the screenshot with the same color coding that was in the last slide,
so it's easier for you to reference.
Again, we start with let and then the source,
then the produce sheet,
which is our navigation step.
Next, promoted headers was our first applied step here in green,
and you can see that it is applied to the prior step in blue.
Then we changed the type of
specific columns and that's referencing the promoted headers step in green.
Then we removed other columns,
and that step references the change type step in purple that we removed duplicates,
which references the removed other columns step in pink.
Finally, we close with in and remove duplicates to close off the M code.
Sometimes it's just easier to update the M code directly.
This is generally when it pays to know a little bit about how the M code works,
so you can tweak it when you want to.
Your two options for making updates are either
by making updates using the query editor pane,
where you can either tweak the M code in the formula bar or select
the little gear symbol to make updates using
the user interface you first use to make that step,
or you can also use the Advanced Query Editor to make updates.
This is my preferred option when I know I need to make
several changes and I want to see the whole picture for my query transformations.
You can get around needing to ever use M by just using the query settings pane.
But it's handy for instances where you want to add
multiple columns back or make other granular tweaks quickly.
As long as you understand the general logic and the pattern of how M works,
you don't need to be fluent to use it.
With both the query setting and Advanced Editor,
you'll leverage the same underlying M code,
you'll just experience it differently.
In either case, you have options to easily delete,
change, reorder steps or insert steps or rename steps.
The critical thing to keep in mind is that the order of those steps matters.
If you try to add a step that doesn't make sense,
say if you add a step that references
a column that doesn't exist based on the prior step,
Power Query will not allow you to make it.